new senior strategic analyst retired
four-star u.s army general jack keane
general it seems to me that pretty much
every day we're seeing some new
developments suggesting that instead of
taking steps to deter putin we're
letting him know that he can deter us
but i'm not a military expert that's why
we have you here what do you think
yeah you put your finger on something
steve for sure because that's been a
pattern of behavior here for some time i
mean going back to 2021
when
putin put 70 000
troops on the ukraine border we had a
shipment going in there that same month
march and april
that was scheduled from the trump
administration of arms and ammunition
and the biden administration delayed it
to august and then when they showed up
in the fall after the afghanistan fiasco
with 170 000 troops we delayed another
shipment and the stated reason
for for delaying both shipments where we
did not want to provoke putin into
attacking
i mean
it is it's outrageous
what happens to this administration it's
the same thing steve that happened with
the obama administration
they get paralyzed by the fear of
adverse consequence and in this case
it's escalation and that is a fearsome
term to them instead of
meeting that
and and doing what we should be doing to
assist the ukrainians being all in
should be what we're doing and we should
not
let putin drive escalation we drive it
ourselves and we certainly
should not let putin get inside of our
head and he's inside of our head that
has a lot to do with the mig-29 deal and
why it's not those airplanes are not now
in the hands of the ukrainians because
we let putin impose his will on us and
and it's shameful but it's
characteristic of the administration
and it's also characteristic of the of
the opposite of what we were promised
which is you know these are the
experienced people the adults in the
room they know how these things worked
out the shambles of that whole story
around the migs this week was really
shocking and embarrassing for america
but but just as on the point of
escalation
i mean to exactly to your point it seems
that this attack on that facility so
close to the nato border specifically um
is targeting it seems those supply lines
and sending a message as well as the
words they use that we we are now going
to consider supply arms supplies arms
convoys legitimate targets they're
trying to deter us from the from what
we're doing even i know you've said it's
not enough but they're trying to stop
the russians trying to stop us even
doing that supplying the arms
yeah that attack was all about
the message being sent to the united
states and allies
on
the resupply routes that were running
primarily out of poland it's not
exclusively
and they're motorized convoy routes uh
bringing those supplies into the
ukrainians yes and they're being
organized in poland and we've got u.s
military involved in a lot of that in
doing all of that and it's and it's
working that's the good thing and they
certainly know that and they're finally
getting around to the realization that
they've got to do something about it
listen the russians have been back on
their heels here for two plus weeks
despite the progress they've made every
inch they have had to fight for and
they're certainly recognizing the
correlation between uh nato resupply in
the ukrainians and the ukrainians
persistent a fight that they're putting
up they're highly related to each other
and and we will likely see
uh some interdiction of those convoys
those convoys are being run by
ukrainians the u.s are not
uh moving over into ukraine to assist
with the convoys they're doing
everything on the nato side of it
so final question very quickly general
um what do you make of this report that
that chechen leader has been seen um if
you like encourage i think the the
reporting was that he was there with
russian
with the russian military urging them
to have faith and keep the fight going
and he's got a terrible record of
brutality
what do you make of that report
well i think it's another reflection of
the
desperation that putin is starting to
feel from what i understand from some
really good sources there was a number
of days when he was not getting accurate
reports about the failings and the
casualties but he started to get that
now and certainly he has some real
concerns
and he he's bringing in syrians uh to do
some fighting he's got the wagner group
uh renamed liga and he's bringing
obviously checking leaders and checkline
fighters
into it but i i none of that in my
judgment is going to be decisive i i
mean it may provide him some comfort
here and it certainly will add to the
fight
but it's his army that has to perform
and certainly they they have
demonstrated
steve that they're poorly led
they're poorly trained they lack
sufficient discipline and that's the
reality i got huge logistics challenges
despite all of that though let's face
what's happening
they are strangling most of all the
major cities
uh in ukraine and they're getting closer
every single day to cutting ukraine off
from the sea in in the south but i think
they're going to have a 10 foot tall
experience trying to take keeve
we've been watching it very close to the
institute for the study of war they
finally got on the outskirts of the city
but they've got to fight their way all
the way down against two mechanized
brigades that the ukrainians have there
they're going to fight them tooth and
nail it's going to be a heck of a
challenge for them just encircle that
city and bring all their artillery to
bear it remains to be seen what's going
to happen there but i know
the ukrainian is going to
give it everything they've got and
they've been working on certainly
reinforcing the city steve now you know
for two plus weeks
yeah but they've they've been given this
time by the russians being bogged down
general jack keane well i'm i know
you'll be watching it and hopefully
we'll get your insight and analysis on
whatever happens in the week ahead we
really appreciate you joining us tonight
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else